this is a cool idea the cabin with bert
kreischer
i i was watching this show and it's a
very good idea because the top of the
show
you're very honest it explains very
quickly that you live a hard
you live hard you live hard you party
hard you work hard
you you like your food you like your
drink you push it and you push it and
you push it
and you finally decided i'm gonna take a
break and i'm gonna go into a cabin
and i'm gonna try and relax and
is that that's the premise of the show
but
initially you were just going to go to a
cabin
and relax and you turned it into a
television show
i do that with everything i did that
with this tour i was like i was like hey
i'm doing a tour in the pandemic i'm
bringing the camera crew
netflix you want it and they're like huh
like i can't help it i just
i think of everything is like wasting
time if i'm not making something
and i like making stuff and so i just
the first person i called was to sagura
and i was like hey you want to come up
and maybe we'll shoot something he was
like yeah
and so he came up and he called joey and
then they got an ounce of weed and
the next you know we're like ah let's
call miss pat and then
joel mchale and then dion and anthony
anderson and it was
and donald rollins bobby lee the list of
guys people that i brought up there to
hang out with me
is my is the are the funniest human
beings
on the planet in my opinion and that's
why people are liking the show is that
you were just letting hilarious people
be hilarious
no boundaries no nothing and uh
and netflix is their guidance was
beautiful and
we're like it was perfect it was a lot
of fun well you know i was
uh i'm good friends with dion cole and
i've known him for a long time and he's
such a hilarious guy
and i just i'm thinking i love just the
concept of dion
out in the woods in a cabin because that
doesn't seem like dion's thing did he
have a good time
it is not dionne's thing dion
like the first thing the first thing we
did that day was because i've always
wanted to
everything i did out there is stuff i
want to do like i want i'm always
looking for a quick fix
right like we got chickens in our house
and i was like i want a beehive i think
a beehive would be cool
so we went to see if we could collect
honey from beehive and dion's like i
don't like bees
and i was like you grew up in chicago
like how can a bee
scare you and he's like i don't like
bees and then he's like
we're getting robbed he goes i like
getting robbed the only thing he really
took to
was spitting on me like he i got stung
by a bee and we were smoking cigars
and they were like you need tobacco spit
and before i could get it out of my
mouth he's spitting on me and i'm like
hey dion i think you got it and he could
not stop spinning on me i was like no he
was this was
this was to help the bee sting he had
totally he was spinning it on you
yeah but he just it was the way he was
doing it was so
just like just just like
i mean he he had so much fun spitting on
me he's like i've never gotten a spit on
a white guy before this is great
i was like am i in trouble with black
twitter i'm using that clip and going
hey guys we're even
yeah yeah yeah no it feels right it
feels like this is good this is a good
catharsis
for you know this is very good i'm glad
that dion got to spit on you